I'd like to take a slight tangent here, very slight and very brief, and look at
a number like this, 6 over the quantity 1 minus the root of 2. Now, at first
sight, this may seem completely unrelated to what we were just talking about.
But I'd like you to focus on the denominator for a second. The problem that I
see with this quantity, and the reason that we can't really do anything with
this fraction right now, is that there's a rational part and an irrational part
in our denominator. I think in general, numbers are easier to work with the
closer they get toward the center of that world of numbers diagram. So, let's
see if we can make our denominator have only one component, probably just a
rational component instead of an irrational one. So, what number would you need
to multiply the numerator and denominator of this fraction by in order to come
up with an equivalent fraction, where the denominator is a rational number and,
of course, it's not equal to 0?